nous allons tout de suite précisément
rejoindre le qg d'edouard balladur le
premier ministre va s'adresser aux
français dans quelques instants
qui est ce que j'aime le meilleur vous
entendez edouard balladur est en direct
sur l'antenne vous êtes en direct sur la
prom se produise
mais edouard balladur rappelons le donc
n'est pas qualifié pour votre second
tour mais edouard balladur dont qui fait
un score tout à fait honorable puisqu'il
se situe tout après proche de jacques
chirac jacques chirac rafles ont
rappelons le
qui donc selon dernier pointage un peu
plus de 20% des suffrages ce qui est une
des surprises sans aucun doute de la
soirée charles millon vous venez de nous
rejoindre vous êtes un udf ralliés à
jacques chirac depuis michel voilà qu'on
va entendre le premier ministre a parlé
avant coopération tout tout démontre que
les français l'ont décidé c'est monsieur
jospin et monsieur chirac qui seront
présents aux je vous demande de vous
arrêter
je vous demande de vous arrêter tout
démontre que les français l'ont décidé
c'est monsieur jospin et monsieur chirac
qui seront présents au second tour de
l'élection présidentielle
je remercie de tout coeur toutes celles
et tous ceux qui m'ont apporté leur
soutien durant ces semaines je me suis
battu pour leur faire partager ma
conviction
l'avenir de la france passe par des
changements profonds une société plus
fraternelle des citoyens plus libre il
passe aussi par davantage d'europe les
français veulent à la fois j'en suis
persuadé le changement et la sécurité
maintenant il faut choisir tout mon
engagement politique est claire je ne
veux pas revoir ce qui s'est passé
en 1981 et en 1988
je ferai tout pour l'éviter pour
deuxième tour au deuxième au deuxième
tour je voterai pour jacques chirac et
je demande à dieu et je demande à tous
ceux qui m'ont soutenu de le faire aussi
c'est ainsi qu'ils sauront le mieux se
faire entendre défendre les convictions
et les projets que nous avons en commun
et qui quoiqu'il advienne représentent
une part importante de l'avenir et de
l'espoir de la france
[Applaudissements]